have you ever thought about
having a vagina put in
installed
whatever ios update yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah below ground pool
[Laughter]
you can climb the ladder for the above
ground but it's just not the same
cause you can get the inside painted and
make it look like you know i didn't do a
whole break
the infinity pool that's a joke you
cannot get the inside your vagina
painted
that was a pool reference
um yeah i mean i've totally thought
about it it's like one of my goals
for sure oh really yeah i mean i just
don't want to talk for for the rest of
my life
um and also to like
that stated right i know
you're talking about the first episode
you were like why would you what a gift
yeah
you talk that's you but for me as a fan
i'm like don't talk i want to see that
dick print i know you do i want to see
you walk around with these pants on
print it up
that's what i want to see so it's like i
don't it's
[Music]
all the [ __ ] he's like don't touch but
stop stop talking i cannot get a fight
that's real though that's real i want to
see it
the print i want to see like oh i was
like you want to what are you what do
you want to do
you've already seen
so and then do you feel a pressure with
your the follow-up would be do you feel
pressure with your career
that there are so many people that do
enjoy the sheenis that
it would affect
your career negatively
if you got the
shine
that sounds so magical
um
uh that has definitely been a concern of
mine for sure because you know i don't
wanna
shoot myself in the foot a little like
yeah i know obviously my audience but my
main reason too is like i love having
sex yeah i think all of us love having
sex and um
if you have had sex with someone who has
had anal you would know that there's
like a lot of preparation that goes into
it yeah so
yeah period king go ahead
tell us about it
go on
yeah i'm just saying like you know that
that digestive system
yeah so it's it's you got it and it's
like think about what you eat
like for real it's real it's real so it
just makes it really hard to have to be
um dealing with that all the time yeah
so i would just like to be like uh
run it up let's go like a gutter [ __ ]
like disgusting
i'm gonna eat mcdonald's i'm gonna put
it all in my mouth
and you're gonna put your mouth on it
cause i don't gotta clean [ __ ] yo oh i
don't gotta clean [ __ ]
and and the
the the [ __ ] that get installed
are they like ready to go is there has
been there but like new technology i'm
not just i'm not really familiar with
the what is it called even
the surgery yeah the bottom it's called
bottom surgery so i'm not familiar with
our ally over here our resident ally in
daisy i hear you coming on the podcast
i don't know mark didn't bring his cross
today
[Laughter]
okay no no so the bottom surgery like
like all surgeries these things improve
yeah right like you even look at like
breasts now compared to like breasts in
the 80s it's crazy right i mean yeah 100
yeah so it's like i imagine bottom
surgery is drastically improving
we haven't even talked about our topic
it's all great
we haven't even moved up yet yeah we're
still down there
but so so i'm like is there part of you
that's like yo i'm gonna wait because
every six months to a year
the pussy's getting out
right yeah
there are children in workshops
sorry apple
um
yeah no i i mean yeah the technology is
obviously getting a lot better it
depends i mean
you just got to go to a good doctor you
know because they're yeah it's just it's
like you gotta go to a good doctor i
love i love
i've seen some things i've seen
some vaginas have you have you had sex
with a uh bottom surgery
um
not with bottom surgery so that would be
a trans
oh wait a minute i feel like that would
be a good way to like like you know you
test drive a car when you want to get
bottom surgery right you see which you
know what doctor you have we'll say i
have my friend natassia dreams
okay
see i knew someone had to see their face
someone saw somebody know my name
i was like oh i knew that would land um
no she showed me her [ __ ] and it was
really fantastic can she feel immaculate
yes and it gets wet the same yes wait
how does it get wet how does it get wet
yeah yeah um
this guy's crazy
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there are different options that you can
get
you can just get a regular vagina yeah
there's also an option like a deluxe the
there's the deluxe what's that deluxe
it's um
they it's like called like the sigmoid
wow i'm so
so medical um it's called the sigmoid
colon version where they take a bit of
your colon
and then they
use it at the top of your vagina and it
helps lubricate more wow yeah cause they
do self-lubricate because oh oh i was
like is that me oh that's natassia
i've seen her yeah i know you have
i know you have for sure
sure um
yeah i know there's like different
options um it depends i mean i don't
know how it works because i'm not a
doctor
but
like someone like semen half of it like
a a small percentage of it is sperm and
like the rest is like seminal fluid yeah
so like it's all coming from like the
same place oh so they can reroute some
seminal fluids yeah yeah and so
obviously like i don't have a g-sp i
wouldn't have a g-spot right but they
place it where your prostate becomes
your g-spot so then you can orgasm
[Applause]